okay so welcome again welcome everyone
thank you for your introductions
um so again our webinar today will be
about bouncing back from a layoff of
erlo
um you know as i mentioned earlier we i
will be answering
answering questions as we go along um
and i'll provide opportunity at the end
as well to answer any questions that you
might
have have that we haven't gone over yet
um feel free to
answer the questions in the chat or and
mute yourself when i do
um you know tell you that we can do that
um and ask questions in that way so i'm
excited about getting started today
so just wanted um to start with a brief
info with some brief information about
myself
so i'm a career coach whose work is
centered around
getting my clients to determine what
they're most passionate about
defining or redefining their why then
creating a fulfilling and purpose-driven
career
and going after those seemingly
impossible dreams
so um i started my career
maybe i would say about 16 years ago
within the hr space i was mainly within
hr and recruiting in the tech space and
you know as much as i loved my career i
loved coming up and i
you know i was definitely very
successful in my career it got to a
point
you know several years ago about five
years ago where it was no longer
fulfilling and you know i
i was making good money i had the
position i had the title had everything
that i wanted but then i had this ache
to do something better and to
feel like my my work was um
making a difference and um and
unfortunately at the time
i felt more like a firefighter than
anything else so
um and that's what brought me into my
love for coaching
is really to just work with all of my
clients and to getting to
what you know to get into what the
challenges are within their career but
going deeper and really figuring out
why is it that they get up every day
what is it that drives them
and then working with them to figure out
how they can make adjustments or create
new careers
that are aligned with who they are okay
um so today's agenda obviously we'll
start with an introduction and then
we'll go over some of the obstacles that
you know some of you or many of you will
be facing during these
um times that we're in um obviously
when it starts with first defining and
redefining yourself
um figuring out what your specialty is
and what your niche areas are
creating your career bucket list um and
then obviously coming into
tactics which is really you know looking
at your resume your linkedin what can
you do about it
well how can you improve your chances of
doing great within those interviews
and then obviously having a tribe or
having one person
um or coach or whatever it may be to
kind of hold you accountable
to what some of your goals are okay
so i'd like to hear from some of you
with a quick poll
i'm not gonna even try and run the poll
on
um on zoom so i would like to if you
could please
all respond on the chat as to what your
current situation is are you
one unemployed a furloughed two employed
but you're kind of feeling insecure and
want to make sure that you have
a backup plan um and then three maybe
you're in a different situation that you
can quickly
tell me what it is so hearing where each
of you are will kind of help me
um know how to direct our conversation
and you know maybe focus on certain
areas of others so if you please
tell me you know what your current
situation is in one two or three
um thank you ryan the rest of you can
respond
um in the chat that would be great
okay so i see some shoes yeah definitely
i feel like a lot of us in that
situation now
if it hasn't happened already we just
don't know when it will but
definitely understand that um anyone
else
okay okay thank you john
anyone else have um one two three
okay thank you andrew
i'd love to hear from a few more of you
um before we
move forward
okay so it looks like a lot in the ones
and two
so um so we'll definitely you know
the whole presentation is geared towards
that so that's great
so let's keep moving um so obviously
the reality of the times where now um
we're in finance you know there's a lot
of financial uncertainty there are
massive cutbacks you know and many
professionals are falling victim
to layoffs to furloughs and to just you
know
um insecurity so obviously getting laid
off can feel isolating and lead to
depression you suddenly thirst into a
job search that you weren't prepared for
and you don't have the right and if you
don't have the right strategy in place
that just only adds into the stress so
unfortunately you know for a lot of us
that's the reality and now
you know figuring out when so many of us
it feels like globally are in the same
situation what can we do you know what
is a strategy that we can
use in order to be successful right and
a lot of times we can kind of get lost
in the despair and the dismay
of things whereas you know in any
situation no matter how
difficult it may be really having a
strategy really coming back to
the basics is what um what really allows
us to be successful
so my goal for this presentation is
really to
help give you a step-by-step guide to
help streamline your job search and so
you have a solid plan of action so you
can get back on your feet and get back
on your feet
fast and again coming up with a strategy
will not only
shorten your job search and help you
land the opportunity that you're excited
about
but i feel like we'll also take a lot of
the stress about the times we're in
um off your hands
okay so i'm a big believer that in
adversity lies the seed of an equal or
greater opportunity
some of the greatest and if you you know
one of my favorite things to
to look at is to look at some of the
stories of
uh in biographies of and read also
of people who have really made it
despite
really really difficult circumstances
despite people believing that they
couldn't do it and
normally it's out of the darkest times
that they are able to come up into their
greatest glory so
even in this situation as dark or as you
know
gloomy as it may seem there is
opportunity
and you just need to go after it you
need to to believe and trust in yourself
no matter what the news cycles are
saying
no matter what your family might be
saying no matter what it looks like on
the outside
you just need to trust and believe that
there is opportunity for each and every
one of us
and it's just up to you to go out and
get in
okay so in scoping out
um the obstacles you know it's good too
important
it's important to know or to think about
really what is holding you back you know
what is holding you back
from one maybe jumping into the job
search two
into maybe getting that opportunity that
you know that you want going after the
companies that you want
maybe it's even from updating your
resume and and
and getting your application materials
maybe it's about you know
refocusing and going after um
a new career that you know you've kind
of held off
and didn't really give it the time or
energy or focus in the past and how was
the opportunity to do that
so really thinking about what is holding
you back what is holding you back from
your best career
you know what is it that scares you and
a lot of times
uh what's holding you back comes back to
your fears
you know so your fear about maybe not
being good enough
you fear about um not knowing enough
not being skillful enough you know a lot
of times i remember for me when i was
coming out
of of you know corporate and starting
to coach you know it was like i was an
expert in my field i had grown i knew it
in and out i can do it in my sleep
and then now i'm coming into a space
where no one knows me i don't have a
name that precedes me
and and so a lot of it was fear that
what if i fall flat in my face what if
i'm not
good at it you know and that's what held
me back for so long
was that fear of uncertainty of not
knowing what
what um was ahead of me and then um and
then also really thinking about
are you content with your current career
path so sometimes the big blessing in
situations like this of being laid off
of being furloughed is really allowing
you the opportunity to think about
did i really you know wow am i really
doing what it is that i want to be doing
and a lot of times
that answer is no you know and uh for a
lot of people who said
you know you hear them um speaking about
their past when they lost a job and they
were heartbroken and they thought it was
the end of the world
they always come back to that with the
biggest blessing you know and why was it
the biggest blessing because it
allowed you the time to really look back
and figure out
what is it that you want you know am i
really aligned with
what i feel i should be doing do does my
job give me joy
or contentedness or satisfaction at the
end of the day where i feel like
i am where i'm supposed to do and i'm
doing exactly what i am
so this is a great time of introspection
to really figure out
you know what is it you know that you
want the fact that you're on
for some of you you know what you want
you know you you know you were doing it
it just so happened that
you are you know the unfortunate
recipient of
you know being laid off or furloughed
and that's great so how can you
re-strategize your path
to make sure that you can continue right
and then for some it's
starting from ground zero and going to
scratch and really figuring out
okay so this no longer aligns with me
what does
um and then you know obviously figuring
out what do you want out of your next
role
right so what is a perf you know and i
love doing this exercise
where i would say what you know in the
perfect world if you
could be given um a magic wand
what kind of career would you create
what kind of company would you work for
what hours would you have in a week you
know would you have a four-hour work
week you know
or you know would you want to be able to
spend 12 hours a day doing what you love
and changing the world you know so what
would that look like and really
you know do an imagination exercise i
did a webinar a few months ago in goal
setting
envisioning and this is such a uh
an important part of you figuring out
what you want next is to first create it
in your mind you know but in the perfect
case scenario not
oh i want to work for google but i'll
never get a job there so
um i wouldn't even think about it a lot
of times we
are our biggest obstacle so really
creating in your mind
what you want your career life to look
like and then
putting it on paper but first it's kind
of just exploring that in your mind
and then in the next step would be
really figuring out
what is your superpower you know so what
defines you or redefines you there's
certain
things about us that are unique to us
that no one else has you know so think
back to your um career
right so what how were you
differentiated from during
um from other employees in your company
you know
what is it that you brought you know
were you always the one who
was um the funny one you know why are
you the one who always brought energy to
events or you would
were you the one who was analytical you
know and were able to figure out
you know and point out things that no
one else could see
were you the one who could see big
picture you know and really be able to
keep
everyone on track of the big picture of
what you're looking for so
how did you bring value to your previous
positions
or even in your life think about it i've
i figured i was a coach because all my
family all my friends came to me for
everything right
um you know i was i started off big in
the holistic health and wellness space
and then you know
and obviously career and personal
development came naturally to me with my
background in hr but
you know everyone would come to me and i
always found myself giving advice
and i found that i loved it you know so
a part of me
really um thrived in the teaching space
in the coaching space and
in giving people tips and and people who
came to me looking for them you know
and um and so that's i knew that's a
value that i gave because in the
workplace i was
always ready to take on and mentor and
teach
and so um to anyone who came to me and
asked so
really figuring out what is your
superpower
and then writing that down you know
really getting
away you know because a lot of us don't
have an awareness of it we take it for
granted
right and then we're just like oh it's
something that i do naturally that you
know i assume everyone does but no
you have your own superpower and and
that is what you're going to use to
define
or redefine yourself when it comes to
your personal value proposition
so the next question is zeroing in on
your special sauce
so we all know that some of the you know
the best restaurants
right um they all have a secret recipe
that they that only they have you know
that's obviously very very guarded
right that make that sets them apart
from
everyone else and what everyone else is
serving right
so again going deeper into the last
question
is to what is your specialty what is
your niche
how can you leverage these two things to
set you apart
you know so there are certain areas you
know within your
um within your space
that you shine right are there any air
you know things that you've studied that
set you apart from
something else so from everyone else and
honestly sometimes it cannot even be
it might not even be related to your
career so i've heard of people who have
expertise in two separate places but
then they can bring them together
and bring even more value to their
positions
by bringing in that you know
that specialty or that niche or whatever
it is that they're able to so again
really zeroing in on what your special
sauce is
writing that down getting to know it
because again this is something else
that you'll be adding to your
um to your you know to your personal
value proposition
and really thinking about you know
things and how you communicate
you know how how do you offer value you
know and just in general
knowing that you know there are a lot of
journalists out there that a lot of
people can do a lot of things
you know but then how what sets you
apart you know employers now want to see
specialists you know i am great at this
and i'm one of the few people that
you'll be able to get
that um is good at it so what are you
specialized in you know
and then write out how you can bring
value and save or
make the company or whoever it is that
you're proposing yourself to
um make a difference to their bottom
line especially
using your specific skills so again
tying into what your special sauce is
tying into
what your superpower is and how you can
use
those things to make a difference to
your employer
or to your business in your next
position
okay so um having said that
i would love to hear some of your
thoughts as to
um what you feel makes you unique and um
feel free to unmute yourself and speak
up
or if you prefer to um at you know
type it in the chat i'd love to hear
that
so what makes you unique um i know for
me
it's just my passion for learning you
know i
you know for any subject that i like i i
just
jump into it i'll learn everything that
i can about it i'll know it inside out
and that's something that really set me
apart um in the workplaces because when
we got projects
especially interesting projects that
came to me i really was
able to uh to go in deeper than most
people because you know i love to learn
you know
and um and also as i mentioned before i
love to teach you know i love to coach i
love to teach so that
is something else that makes me really
unique and help me stand out
in my um career so
um would any of you tell me what you
feel makes you unique in the workplace
in your personal life
and maybe some of your skills talents
and abilities maybe in some of your
hobbies
what is it that really um sets you apart
feel free to unmute yourself or type in
in the chat
okay do i still have everyone just type
a yes if you're still there
great adaptability that's a great skill
right
being willing to dive into anything that
needs to be done that's
excellent um john that's a tough
question yeah it is and honestly
it you know we don't take enough time to
think about such things and this
is how we present our value this is our
own personal marketing material that we
use to give to the world right so really
thinking through it and honestly
you know you might not be able to answer
it right now that's fine
but just make a note of it and really do
an exercise
after our call this session will be
recorded so um and we will post it on
our um on our career site on youtube but
really just think through
what is it that makes you unique and
actually list it out you know
list everything that you can think about
and if you can't think of anything
ask your family members ask your
uh you know anyone in your life your
friends who know you well and ask them
would you
or even co-workers right or former
co-workers
and ask them how what do you feel set me
apart from anything else what were
certain
things about me you know that that
really
you know you felt set me apart and a lot
of times they'll also be able to give
you insight that you might not be able
to see because again
you're speaking for your own life so
that so it might be difficult to see it
in that sense
okay um flexibility again that's
great on being able to analyze
situations and choose an approach to a
solution that's
excellent um so we'll go on to the next
slide so again
coming back to we looked at what your
superpower is we looked at what your
specialty and niche is
so what are some of your skills right
and this is a little bit easier
right because we build our lives on our
skills so what are some of your soft
skills you know
um you know i'm a people person and i am
a good communicator you know i'm
analytical i'm flexible and adaptable
you know all those things
are part of your soft skills right um i
work well in teams
again writing all of these down don't
just think them off in your head
write down what are my soft skills and
then think about your technical skills
as well
think about anything that you may have
learned you know
not and not just technical you know
anything that
you you need specifically for your
position
or you know or that you use in your
career that you have to be trained on
or that's not just general knowledge so
thinking about what some of those
technical skills are
and then in looking at both your soft
skills and technical skills
think about what skills are transferable
to the role
that you are looking to get so maybe you
might be looking to make a career pivot
right so maybe you were working as a
teacher and you're looking to move into
data science right
so what skills did you need
as a teacher or did you have as a
teacher both soft skills and technical
skills
that can you then transfer to data
science and it's actually having on
paper you'll be able to see
because now um figuring out the position
that you want to go in what are the kind
of skills required
and here i normally give recommendations
to do an exercise where
you're actually looking at several and
this is for people who are new and to
um who are looking to pivot into a new
career we're really looking at several
job descriptions whether it's 10 or 15
going through and highlighting all the
skills that are required
then it becomes very clear what's
important to employers
both on the soft side and the technical
side and then thinking back to your
experience in the past
and figuring out what skills that you've
had can be transferable
and um and then going from there so
things again like communication
things like team building things like
you know for example if i was a math
teacher and i'm moving into data science
a very analytical uh field you know i
need to be strong in math so again
they're not exactly related but there
are transferable skills and sometimes
you need to
you know kind of figure them out you
know
they're just not there on the surface
but it's definitely important to
to think about this to write them down
as they are specific to you
okay so the next stage would be to
create a career
bucket list so going back to what i said
earlier creating this
career perfect day perfect what would my
perfect work week look like what would
my perfect
day look like in the career in my career
so start with creating
a list of companies that you want to
work for you know so some of us
have um you know went to work for some
really cool startups you know
i i would love to work for tesla just
for that you know i love the brand
you know some people a lot of people in
town work for the googles and
facebooks and some of the tech giants
you know so what is important for you
in a company right so list out a few
companies that you'd really
um see yourself working for
and then research research the companies
because a lot of times
um they look good on the outside like a
lot of um
students will reach out to me and they
will say
um you know i really want to work for
this company i really want to work for
that company and ask them why you know
and the googles are the standard right
so i'm like so why do you want to work
for google
and a lot of times i'll find what they
really want
doesn't align with the culture of google
you know google is a huge company you
know you go in there you have to prove
yourself and you're competing with
people that
are the best of the best of the best in
the field you know so it's hard to be
seen it's hard to be
you know and you work you know whereas
you know for me i know i need to work in
a smaller company where i can be seen
where i can feel like my work is making
a difference where i can feel like i
have
um you know i have some kind of
access to management you know
and so for me that's important so i know
i could not thrive
in that kind of environment as good as
it may look on the outside so again
really figuring out what is important to
you
you know and these companies you know
although on the outside they might look
great
do they really align with your
personality
with who you are and what some of your
goals are
and so um so this is this is really key
and then coming back and you know
editing that list you know and you might
decide
oh you know i really would thrive in a
small or medium business i
really would thrive in a startup or or
no i would not you know do well in the
startup
i really need to be um in a larger
company that has very defined roles
and that can support me in you know
getting to be really specialized in what
it is that i'm doing
um so again thinking about what your
goals are and then see how they align to
your
um career bucket list so and to add to
this
don't just make a list of companies
also think about positions you know i
remember reading an article about
a lady once who you know she lost her
job
and then she decided you know what i
don't really i have no
idea what it is that i want to do so she
made a list of
everything that she ever thought would
be a cool job you know
some including being an organic farmer
some included being a travel blogger
some include you know like
every random position that she ever
thought that
oh that could be cool to do she actually
wrote it down
she made a list of ones that she'd
actually you know she gave herself two
years she sold everything
and she gave herself a chance to
experiment and try
each of these dream jobs that she had
you know so she kind of literally went
through
a career bucket list when she was so
young and then at the end of the two
years she really figured out which
what it is that she wanted to do plus
she had great experience
with just trying out all these other
different things so thinking about
what are positions that i think would be
so cool
right um to have and then seeing whether
it's something that you can actually go
after right now
so would it be um you know
uh you have the time now right so i
decide okay i would love to
pursue a position in finance i would
love to see what it would be like to do
this kind of position then what kind of
skills
you need what are the barriers to entry
how can you get in there and then you
start the research talking to people who
are in those roles
figuring out a way but it first starts
with you kind of figuring out
so i would like to take a pause here um
first with any questions that you might
have um so far from what we've gone over
and then two to also ask you if you
could work
anywhere where would you choose oh
if you could choose anything it doesn't
have to be working for a specific
company but
if you could choose anything that you
uh that you could you know that would
obviously pay your bills that would
obviously support you
um but then you know choose whatever it
could be
you know i want to be a farmer i want to
be
a landlord you know whatever it would be
what would be
your thing what would you choose
and again feel free to unmute yourselves
or
um or type in the chat
yeah hi this is dennis king yes dennis
hey
yeah so my my um if i could work
anywhere i i would choose a place where
um i would be able to do
the things that leverages on my skills
okay however the type of work
that i'm looking for at the moment since
you know companies are looking for
somebody who have
a quantitative background a phd degree
so that comes
to me as a roadblock for pursuing uh
hi dennis yeah yeah okay i thought i
lost you
okay
so yes so
yes i don't know how much you got that
um i don't know if i was cut off
yeah so i heard that you mentioned that
you know so you
have your the job that you want to do
where you want to use your skills
however the roadblock is most companies
are looking for
really um people who have phds or who
are very educationally advanced
right yeah
okay and so do you know anyone in this
field that has been able to get roles
without
that level of education um i have not
most of the job process that i've seen
so far
and really kind of appeal to me um that
i
really want um to do as something i
would like to do um
those require uh basically is
looking for somebody who has um phd
degrees
or uh some other data background which i
don't have
i'm more than software development and
devops
i'm trying to move to a machine learning
and data science field so that kind of
get
yeah and you feel confident in your own
ability to do those jobs so if you're
for example you came across a job
description the job looks interesting to
you
do you feel like you have the skill
required even without the phd
i i feel like i do but i'm also trying
to be realistic
i'm i know that um i
i have some a little bit of ways to go
for um
you know in statistics but
so i've done a couple of udacity courses
like machine learning
and i'm also presenting master's degree
in data science so i'm trying to get
better with
quantitative experience and course work
but i've done a couple of course works
already
uh one is human activity recognition as
part of the coursework in my
university um i've done some
marketing analysis or clustering for
a company in germany as part of the edac
work other coursework too offered in
in udacity courses so i'm very
comfortable with some of the skills
but i'm not exactly sure like what
exactly are companies looking for
for somebody who has a phd degree
that i cannot perform yeah yeah and
honestly
and just to kind of quickly answer your
question and we can go deeper
um in this if we have time at the end or
maybe you can
ping me and we can set up a one-on-one
call um because i'd really love to
explore this with you
um but what i would suggest for you is
really
doing research in the field so yes you
have built your skills
from a theoretical perspective but then
from a practical
perspective how much do you really need
right
and that will come to speaking to
actually cut okay so you know certain
companies that you want to work for
right go back and look at people who are
working at these companies
so use linkedin for example find you
know machine learning engineers or
whatever it may be
within the companies that you want to
work for look at their profiles and see
what their
background was and their career
progression i'm sure there'll be some of
them
that haven't gone the traditional route
you know because a lot of times
employees will write job descriptions
very you know
to just the traditional the career path
looks like this however they're more
concerned about skills
right so looking at what actual people
in those roles um the kind of skills
that they hold
and then especially focusing on the ones
that haven't
had those advanced degrees i you know i
hear from several machine learning
engineers who don't have phds
so it is possible so your job will then
to be seek them out
on linkedin on any tech groups that you
might be in
you know and actually find out so you
didn't go
that route but you're still able to
become a machine learning engineer some
of the companies you're interested in
what what did you do how did you set
yourself apart
how were you able to present your skills
in order
for employers to feel that yeah you know
they might not have this phd but yeah
they can still do the job does that make
sense yes it does thank you so much yeah
and uh also i would like to yeah um
i'll try and schedule a one-on-one with
you yeah you know
okay awesome yeah do that and we'll be
able to go deeper and i can give you
specific
um suggestions for your situation but
yeah it would be helpful for us to be
able to um to actually
speak one-on-one okay okay thank you
you're welcome um so i see a response
from john
big tech where i can solve global
problems in education healthcare and
things of that nature that's great
um and andrew space something like
monitoring development of satellites
another wow that's amazing
so again recommending you know each of
these areas if they're not already on
your radar
get to know them make it a part of your
life you know start following space
companies start following big tech
companies
start looking at companies that are
looking to make a difference john for
you i would
focus on uh websites like built-in that
are all focused on you know
solving problems right and um and
there's a few others as well
um i'll try and think of and i'll
mention them at the end
but really focusing on um on companies
and
groups that you know enable you to
um to to link up with you know
what it is that you really eventually
would
love to be doing okay
so from jeremiah software engineer
value where i can grow and learn with
more experienced engineers and also
somewhere that's fun
again that's great uh so let's
move on so now we've talked a lot about
really figuring out
you know what is it what are your
strengths what can you bring
you know so now the next part is tactics
actual tactics that you can use
in order based on the information that
we've learned right
so first revamping your resume
obviously this is key because it is your
marketing material right
and the better your resume can be the
better you'll be able to present
yourself to the world to companies you
know and always like to equate
you know if you're going to the store
and you're needing to buy toothpaste for
the first time and you have no idea
which brand to buy
a lot of times you will go with the one
that has the best
advertising right or has the mo you know
the most
interesting packaging right so your
resume is your packaging
okay so it really takes some time and
effort initially
right to really look at it to make sure
that it's presenting you in the best
light possible because a lot of times
i've seen such you know greatly talented
people but then they have really crappy
resumes that do not represent
their background their skills their
experience the value that they bring
so really look at really looking at your
resume and keeping in mind
all of the other things that we've
discussed right so what is your
superpower what is your specialty or
niche
what transferable skills do you have
what value can you add on
right and making sure that you have all
of these represented
in your resume so taking what we've
learned from the previous
um steps and making updating your resume
to really show your skills
and i'll also um say that you should
always have written your resume for the
position that you want
so for example i'm looking to transition
i'm a software engineer today and i'm
looking to transition
into becoming a data scientist most of
my experience has been written for
my software engineering experience so we
have our
our application materials generally are
written for the experience that we
had so we need to take it a step further
and actually
write them for the position that we want
so
what an employer would be looking for
from a software engineer is going to be
very different from what an employer is
looking for from a data scientist
so one going back to the job description
exercise
looking at those several job
descriptions figuring out
what is important to employers you know
again you've gone through each of them
you've highlighted what the skills are
you've circled um the ones that you're
lacking and so
it's made it very clear to you this is
what is important to employers
for these type of roles then making sure
your resume is written for that that
you've included
keywords that you've constantly seen
being brought up in
those um job descriptions and look even
look at other
um people who are within the space look
at their resumes see
what you know how they've written it's
easy to pull up resumes now using google
using
um linkedin and seeing what you know
what are some of the right things people
have done how have people
um presented their experience you know
when you're
um it's so important to have a career
summary you know
an object an objective is a waste of
time but really having a career summary
that speaks to
all of your strengths experience
abilities education as it relates to the
position that you want so that way in
that paragraph
at the top of your resume you are
stating this is how
these are the strengths that i bring to
this position this is what i'm looking
for
um but yeah i'm really taking the time
we have
great resources um or getting your
resume reviewed so definitely you know
udacity has a review process
you can submit it through a career
project um you can also
if you have one-on-one calls you can
upload your resume and you can have a
career coach look at it as well and give
you
additional recommendations but
definitely revamp your resume
now is the time uh more than ever and
make it the best representation of you
um then the next stage would be
optimizing your linkedin profile so a
lot of people
you know i'm not sure how many of you
have linkedin profiles or not
now it's almost something that you have
to have you know it's
no longer an option right that's kind of
like your online representation
of yourself professionally so making
sure that your linkedin is optimized
making sure that
you know you have what it is that you
want in your header it should be clearly
stating what your strengths are you know
what your skills are
you know in your about section that
should be your career summary you know
and what you're about
you know speaking to the jobs that you
have speaking to the projects that
you've worked on
but really optimizing your linkedin
profile because
a lot of times recruiters or employers
will
first go on there you know then they
might not have access to your resume
but they'll first go on there to kind of
see what you're about and a lot of
recruiters are also
using linkedin as their primary
um uh source for candidates i know that
i have you know in
any recruiting that i do today in
probably the last five or ten years
linkedin has been my primary source for
um for
looking for candidates and no longer do
i use monster and leader and mobile site
so
making sure that your linkedin is up to
par you have a good picture
and again we have a review process for
that you can put um
you can put it through a project you can
have one of our career coaches look at
it
so um making sure that it's key and also
looking at other people's linkedin
profiles that are in your space
so for example if you're a ux designer
then you need to
be able to show how creative you are so
then
your linkedin profile should be more on
the creative side you know if you're
um an engineer or whatever it may be
look at what
you know some of the other um uh what
your peers
have done with their profiles and i
always learn even today i'll look at
what other coaches have done
that distinguish it you know themselves
and or that really
help present their um their backgrounds
and their experience in a good way and
then i take that and tweak mine
to reflect that so optimizing your
linkedin profile
then obviously preparing for your
interviews you know that goes without
saying
there's a behavioral interview so making
sure that you're able to answer
questions about yourself
you know really having that elevator
pitch in your mind
knowing your strengths you know because
a lot a lot of the behavioral interviews
go into what some of your strengths are
how you've dealt in certain situations
how you know you've
shown to be flexible how you've shown to
be
you know a team player whatever it may
be and again really understanding what
the company's culture
is and what is important to that company
and then
defining your answers based on that
right so thinking back to situations and
this is for your interviews
that align with what you know is
important for that particular role
for that particular company so again
interview prep
you know the technical interviews you
know again doing
you know there's so much so many
websites out there now
that help you with a technical practice
depending on your area of focus
um there's lots of um help online on
behavioral interviews
you know udacity we do mock interviews
so you you want to do that schedule a
one-on-one
call but you know you probably if it's
technical you probably need to give the
questions to the
um to the uh coach
prior to the call because you know we
definitely are not technical but
if it's um behavioral we can do that but
yeah just
take this time to really prepare
yourself in each of these ways
um you can you know in addition to doing
the mock interviews
also learning you know so many of the
interviews that are happening today
are happening online so how can you
present yourself in the best way
possible
you know so looking at tips you know
where to position yourself
lighting sound you know because all of
these now make a difference in how you
present yourself to employers
you know and again practicing having a
family member or a friend
you know call you in doing a zoom mock
interview you know so that way you're
even recording it right so that way
you're able to see yourself how you're
being seen by employers
and then um being able to put your best
foot forward whether
the interview is online whether it's on
zoom
or some other video service um
and then the the last part is really
networking and i cannot stress this
enough and i
know this is an area that uh comes to be
a big
challenge um to a lot of people because
again it takes us out of our comfort
zone
it's putting ourselves out there to
people that we don't know who might not
necessarily know us
but to be honest with you all the
students that i've had
who've had success during this time that
we're in who have been able to land jobs
during covet
you know in the worst of it um have been
ones who have
really put in the time and and built
good networks
even during the pandemic or had already
solid networks before so really working
on your networking again i can go into
detail in a lot of these things because
we are so you know we're so short on
time when we have an hour
but we have lots of other webinars on
our
youtube channel that have specifically
gone into
interview prep they've specifically gone
into networking that's specifically gone
into updating your linkedin
or your resume so go back look at those
listen to them
you know set up one-on-one calls if
you're struggling in one area or another
we need to learn how to focus in one
area of another
and we're happy to support you
so the last recommendation is
really building a career and
accountability tribe and this kind of
ties back into
your network as well i you know a lot of
people just think network is adding
connections on linkedin
and it's more than that you know it's
really creating connections with people
right so i've connected with you on
linkedin but then i reach out to you
because you're someone that i admire
you're someone who's background that
i want to um you know i want to learn
more about
i want to learn from because maybe i can
take some of this
i can do some of the things that they
you know have done to be successful
so then taking that next step reaching
out to the people
making um and having informational
interviews with them
and that way they're getting to know you
you're getting to know them and you're
figuring out where
they sit within your network some will
be you probably never have another call
with them
someone will you have such a great
connection that there will be someone
that you ask to be a mentor
or some will be a peer that you continue
to kind of have in your cohort in your
career
um for the rest of your career so
really creating intentionally creating a
career and accountability tribe
right now coming back to the situation
that we're in we're
laid off we're furloughed we're not
motivated we're discouraged you know
so really figuring out who can i have as
my
accountability partner there's so much
that i need to do
i need to update my resume i need to
work on my linkedin i need to up skill
i need to network i need to do all these
things
how do i keep myself accountable to
getting all of these things done
right and find someone else who's also
looking to do the same thing
right so so that way you you are
bouncing off of each other you're
keeping each other accountable so this
week
we're going to focus on doing one two
three four things
then you check in with each other at the
end of the week you know a lot of times
in these you know when i've had
accountability partners
when i was down they were up when i was
up they were down but
knowing that we could always rely on
each other is what helped us
get to the finish line same thing goes
when you start going to the gym you're
so much more successful when you have
someone that you're going with you know
that you're they're waiting on you to
show up you know at six a.m
in the um in the morning and if you know
oh it's just up to you to get up and get
out of bed at 5 30 and make it to the
gym at six
most likely you're only accountable to
yourself so it's easy to say ah i'm not
gonna show up right
but when you know someone else is
waiting on you to show up
you tend to it makes it easier um
to show up so um so definitely
look for that i love that jeremiah said
that he likes the
idea and is reaching out so if any of
you are interested do that
we also have the student hub career
channel you can post on there
and and look for accountability partners
who are also other udacity students
we also have a um a linkedin
alumni page for udacity that's another
great place to post and look for
accountability partners
but yeah great um first step and and
create that you know it starts with one
partner
but also create a career tribe people
who are like-minded people who are doing
the things that you want to be doing
people who are in the careers that you
want to be in
and then also mentors right because you
can learn so much
why create a path when there's already
one that's kind of been
um done for you right so you can learn
so much from mentors
but you have to seek these people out
you have to first set the intention to
create this tribe
and then actually reach out to people
and you know start adding make your
intentions known
and start adding them to your tribe so
um so those are some of the tactics that
i find
um you know they i know for some of you
don't seem really basic
but really this is what will help set
you apart
and having the strategy and using these
tactics
you know i've worked with students where
i've seen it time and time and time and
time again
work so this is what i would really
suggest
um for you to you know that could really
make a difference for
in your job search now and in you being
able to net to land your next role
okay so i must have
so here is a time where i would like to
see what kind of questions that you have
um if we can kind of just come back to
what
bringing back together what we've gotten
gone through right so we started with
strategy and tactics
and patience are the keys to navigating
the current environment
you know so scoping all your obstacles
figuring out what your superpower
is and what your special sauce is right
so what what is your value add what is
your personal value proposition
and then you know creating that bucket
list and getting into it and researching
it
giving your application materials a
makeover so your linkedin
your your github your
um cover letters your resume all of that
obviously bring putting your best foot
forward and smashing those interviews
and then creating that career and
accountability
um so so this is some of you know so
this is just a summary of kind of what
we've gone over
um and so that brings up brings us
to the last five minutes of our call i
hope that would have a few more
um minutes for our q a but
you know you could go ahead and maybe
ask any questions that you have that i
might not have gone over
and um and we can answer them now so
feel free to unmute yourself
or ask the questions in the chat um so
say a question from ryan i've noticed
that
we're transferring for uh to another
career it's much harder to simply apply
to
jobs yes right you have to have a
strategy above
just applying you need to be able to
have that network you need to talk to
people who are in those positions
already
figure out how they were able to get
into their first position
right because everyone at some point was
new seeing what kind of companies they
work for seeing what kind of
opportunities that they have because a
lot of times
you know especially now not a lot of
jobs are posted
right so you have to do a little bit
more digging to find out what's open
and then a lot of times you will find
out what is
truly open and available and you know i
have students who were able
just from their network to be able to
get referrals for positions
or even have positions created for them
um because
that person understood what their um
what their strengths were so when you're
transferring to another career you have
to have a multi-prong strategy so one
is really building that network two is
showing how
being able to showcase some of the
experience that you have had
so udacity is great because you get
projects that you
can actually work on um that you can add
to your portfolio
but then take it a step above that can
you do maybe some volunteer
work or can you do an internship and i
know some of you are working so it's not
possible but
you can do it on a part-time basis you
can do it on the weekends you can
you know support a friend who maybe has
started a new business and even
needs some design um support or some
you know software development whatever
it may be
so seeing any opportunity that you can
to show um that you have hands-on
experience
also really helps in in going a long way
into proving to employers that you do
have
the uh the background needed to do the
job
okay any other questions
uh i have a question this is andrew hey
andrew
um i
have a great deal of education
in stuff that is not related to where i
want to
where i'm going or okay haven't been
able to find something
how do i
how do i justify the sunk cost of
though of that education
who are you justifying it too uh an
employer
because i have an mba and i'm
not looking for a business something
anymore well
you don't need to if you're not looking
for a business
um business position right or something
that's related to your mba
then whatever it is that you're looking
for you don't need to prove to them
why you have an mba because your focus
will not be on that area
does that make sense so yes
yourself in the best way um so
how do my skills abilities background
experience
align with the position that i want now
right
so if that mba doesn't align then i
wouldn't highlight it in my
in my application materials you can have
it to show that yes i have this
education
but i won't bring it to the forefront so
then they won't question it
okay that's very good thank you very
much you're welcome
you're welcome um so
i see another question from dennis is
having an employment gap in your resume
a red flag for companies
it can be and it all depends on
how long the gap is for but honestly if
you can
explain the gap right like for example
just put a one-liner
where you say i was pursuing you know
for example maybe you took a personal
leave of absence for
three years right or you took an absence
to raise your kids or whatever it may be
see how you can creatively present that
gap
so within that three years was there
anything that you did that you can say
contributed towards your new career or
that still continued your development
in your current career so maybe you did
a few projects so maybe you took a few
courses so maybe
you know what is it that you did within
that gap that might have contributed
positively
to who you are now and maybe being able
to write that out instead of just
keeping a gap
so again strategy on how to address
various gaps we can talk about in more
detail if i know what it is
what the gap was about i can give you
specific strategies on how to
one explain it um when you ask and then
two
also in how to present it in your
application materials in a way that
um that employers are not like oh
they've been out for too long
they won't be a fit and then i'm
thinking of focusing on my master's and
completing udacity courses before i get
back to the workplace
again that's a very personal decision if
you feel that that's something
that will bring you value and and
and help you in getting to the next
stage of your career if it aligns with
your longer term goals
then great but i do want to say that you
know a lot of the students that
call you know that i talk to every
single day have masters
have phds and so the education alone is
not enough to set you apart
you know really it should be in
combination with
everything else so yes i'm building my
skills i'm building my education
but i'm also building my network i'm
building my portfolio and my hands-on
skills
so how do you you know keep a balance
and dance between the three
um in order to make sure that even when
i do complete my education
i am able to get a job um that i want or
that's aligned with what my goals are
i hope that answered your question um
dennis
great and ryan i hope i answered your
question as well is there
any other questions as we come into the
last
um minute uh last few minutes walk all
we're actually a little bit over but
i'll take one last one
um for the day
okay it looks like we are good to go so
i would like to tell you that um
we have weekly ask me anythings where we
have career coaches on there
normally it's at least two of us
sometimes it can be up to four career
coaches and we're on for one hour
at 9 00 a.m pacific time every tuesday
um so it's a weekly event where you can
come in
you can ask any career related questions
it's very informal
so you know there's no particular agenda
or
um anything that we follow so we're just
really there to answer any questions
that you have to engage with you
there are also a lot of students on
there and what we found is
we'll find one student who has
experience of ten years of one field and
someone who has
one year or trying to break in and a lot
of times they're able to offer value to
each other
um so it's a great place to connect with
other students to connect with coaches
so definitely join us every tuesday 9
a.m pacific
it's 12 noon um eastern u.s time to see
what time zone that is for you
um and we can continue to answer your
questions there
um also we have one-on-one sessions if
you have
um access to them please schedule we can
go in in depth in any area that you're
struggling in but again use us you know
add us to your
um to your career try to your
accountability tribe
i know i hold a lot of my students
accountable in sticking to their job
search and what they're looking to do so
take advantage of that we have our
youtube channel that has all of our
uh past webinars um posted on there we
have
webinars almost every week so go to
udacity.com
events and you'll see all the upcoming
webinars so yeah we're definitely here
to support you we know it's a
frustrating time but
you know it's just having a strategy
creating a support system
and that's what will really get you
through so i really appreciate all of
your time today
um feel free to message me on the
student hub if you have any questions
that i wasn't able to get to today
but i'm wishing you all a great weekend
and all the best with your continued
career search
thank you very much thank you
hmm